my name is Benny central spam fish my  name's camp Brad or the gaming lemon and  I'm a youtuber I'm a presenter I'm a  gaming youtuber I'm a streamer but today  I'll loan to become a soldier a soldier  a soldier a soldier whoa I've got this  guy Mike in the sniper over here get him  hitting with your sword Obama okay let's  go let's go around behind it I'm westie  I'm a seasoned battlefield player brutal  battle going on there and it's fallen to  me to take these for battlefield one  novices from corporals I have never  ridden a horse before get on boy let's  go too generous boom out a shot welcome  to battlefield Academy  in just two days we'll have to learn how  to ride a horse drive a tank fly a plane  and work as a squat it's down great wife  nice one boys well we're battle ready  we'll take the fight to you I'll and by  air YC live on launch day  you  play it first with EA access